[Applause]  oh  [Music]  i am not scared of anyone except the  almighty i thought of him  he was the one who gave me the strength  and now all this respect i am very  grateful  [Music]  hello  [Music]  it's not even only affecting our  education it's also affecting our mental  health it's really hurtful to see our  own friends going against us and telling  no i have a problem with her wearing  hijab after five years of studying  those students who wore the hijab  started this role first if they ended we  will also end it if they were a hijab  then we are also forced to wear saffron  to compete with them  [Applause]  [Music]  once you have stirred  poison into this  otherwise uh learning  areas  well it might many people may use it for  different reasons at in different stages  so that could be one of the  um you know most unfortunate thing that  might happen here hereafter  [Music]  you